ou la russie elle voit ses bases
militaires frappés par des incendies
pour la deuxième fois en moins d'une
semaine en crimée un dépôt de munitions
a été le théâtre la nuit dernière d'une
explosion mme elisabeth vous êtes pour
france24 actuellement à kiev que sait-on
de ses attaques sur la grille mais
tu écoutais rafael vous avez raison ces
attaques elles sont répétées depuis un
peu plus d'une semaine il y en a eu pas
moins de 3 la semaine dernière une
attaque a frappé une base aérienne sur
laquelle au moins neuf avions militaires
russes ont été détruits une attaque qui
n'a pas été revendiquée directement par
keefe mais les renseignements
britanniques ont confirmé que c'était
bien les autorités ukrainiennes qui
avait frappé sept bases aériennes
les américains également confirmé tout
en précisant que ce ne sont pas les
armes fournies par leur pays qui ont
permis ces frappes comme toujours les
les russes et les ukrainiens se
renvoient des responsabilités les russes
qui à ce moment là disait qu'il
s'agissait d'un simple accident et les
ukrainiens qui se moquaient un petit peu
des russes en disant oui il ne faut pas
fumer auprès de ces de ces centres de
dos ses bases militaires il ya eu une
attaque vous l'avez dit cette nuit une
deuxième attaque en crimée qui a frappé
cette fois un dépôt de munitions et
surtout qui a endommagé un
transformateur endommageant un chemin de
fer qui est utilisé par les russes
depuis la crimée pour transporter des
munitions jusqu'au sud de l'ukraine
occupé en partie par les forces russes
et puis on a eu des nouvelles cet
après-midi un d'une troisième attaque
donc ce sont des témoins qui ont affirmé
avoir vu une explosion de la fumée et
s'agirait d'une d'une base aérienne
appartenant à la marine russe cette fois
qui aurait été touché une base aérienne
sur laquelle se trouve au moins douze
avions stationnés on ne sait pas encore
si cela était endommagé dans tous les
cas et bien cela intervient dans un
contexte de contre offensive menée par
l'ukraine dans le sud de notamment pour
récupérer un rêve qui a été prise par le
russe il ya quelques mois une contre
offensive qui est compliqué par la
proche de l'automne alors que le terrain
va devenir difficilement praticables
d'ici à novembre peut-être même dès
octobre merci